ok jetzt hier live und alle starts to
grow ich sie gar nichts man sieht
einfach nichts wenn man in so ein
gebäude drin ist ist es der overkill das
der absolute backe
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen videospiel heute jump league
und wir haben heute eine challenge ihr
euch so oft gewünscht habe deswegen
market hat man ausprobieren ich weiß
nicht wie's läuft wir schauen einfach
und zwar die f15 hergestellt von rudolf
rasputin sagt im spiel eine komplette
runde auch pvp 5 modus viel glück bei
der charity golf vii probieren unser
bestes wir versuchen unser glück und wir
springen in die runde so leute runde
wir aktivieren den fünf monaten wir
sehen ja difficulties und ich sage euch
dieses modul ist gar nicht so easy 5
modus da können wir auf jeden fall schon
mal den albanern jump fehlt sammeln
das könnte tricky werden okay das haben
die safety car phase so schräg aus dass
sich im wahrsten sinne des wortes schräg
aus
die jetzt nein das hat in das amerika
märchen bis dato noch kein jumptel alles
klar
ganz ganz locker ganz gut hier hoch da
will ich jetzt fast double gum am
liebsten ja wohl klappt klappt und wir
rutschen über den nächsten druck darüber
nein
schade man sagt okay das jetzt nicht so
schwierig wie sieht es hier aus die
doppelstrategie ist glaube ich sehr gut
für diese f5 challenge okay gut und
jetzt hier schön um die ecke ganz
relaxed ob da hoch genau der mich fast
runtergefallen
diese blöden stelle und jetzt checkpoint
allesklar.de erster check point ist
erreicht und dürfen nicht übermütig
werden
hier bauen bei uns wird bei uns in die
ecke und das ist auch schon mal ein
schwieriger sprung aber wenn man
geschafft und wir können hier luden ihr
seht auch wie das luton aus sydney ist
es so komisch man ist so komisch wie
einfach da ob der kiste drauf stehen und
nach unten schauen weil sie in den boden
nur um treten soll unsere items aus der
krise raus bekommen zu können
ok-chef mir nochmal den schaffner sogar
noch mal und jetzt als topmodel ist auch
schwierig das ist wieder einer max
listen sprung
jetzt haben wir es jetzt haben wir es
hier sehr schön und das effektvoll alles
klar
die ersten module waren alles andere als
sie muss man sagen gerade für uns die
wir jetzt hier so ein bisschen im jahr 5
modus bisschen leiden wenn es für mich
ist es gerade mega mega mega intensiv
was die konzentration angeht ag passt
aber soweit hier sind wir und wir haben
noch eine weitere gäste jede jazz die
wir holen ist eine errungenschaft leute
das ist gar nicht so easy ja okay und
hier ist noch ein checkpoint alles klar
und das ist modul es geht eigentlich
nicht schon mal als ob man mein kopf
steckt einfach an den lehrern was nicht
so was wir sehen ist ich hab mich
einfach nach oben tpg
so fühle ich mich einfach ich die prämie
die ganze durch die gegend ok dann gibt
es aber jetzt hier nur einen punkt wo
man ziemlich ideal abspringen kann
glaube hier live check point ist da sehr
schwer über mord beim neuen modell würde
fast sagen wenn jeder rechts hinschaut
sind wir reis lukaku in der tat
man gibt entwickeln einfach ein gespür
für die nicknames und zwar auch soweit
ganz gut reicht auch konzentration
die spanier sind sie erstmal in diesem
modul überhaupt die sprünge
ich weiß es nicht aber es ist alles sehr
tricky eigentlich will man hier im f 5
modus unterwegs ist ihr wollt es recht
und hier jetzt ich kann heute überhaupt
nicht sinnvoll kommentieren die macht
die ganze zeit kommen und welche grund
geräusche aber ich komme kommt damit
klar denkt nicht dass es die
nachvertonung für einen pornofilm ist
das ist nämlich nicht sondern es ist es
ggf 5 modus gespielt und es auch hier so
weit alles safe bot das ist halt so ein
langes modell
es ist so verdammt lang gehört aber das
sollte man jetzt endlich auch nicht mehr
fehlen hier oben sieht gut aus dass
jetzt eigentlich auch eine relative
station nummer oder neiße rollte während
die hoch geschafft die ggg das hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass es so schnell geht
br virgin cosworth armin nack ob web
wickens alle armen accambray und zack
und das ist jetzt wieder ein sehr
schwieriger sprung können den schaffen
wir schaffen ihn nice märz haben wir das
modul was auch gar nicht so easy ist
aber sind wieder relativ weit vorne
jetzt müssen wir hoch m coupé wir da da
ist die kiste ist klick klick klick
klick klick erste kiste alles klar sagt
man jetzt heißt es durch metro und noch
mehr schwung und jawohl wir haben's
geschafft und wir sind tatsächlich bei
den hart modulen leute ich jetzt nicht
gedacht wir haben es bis zu den alten
ruhm geschafft mf5 modus man das ist so
komisch okay jetzt hier und alles da
jetzt tue ich sie gar nichts man sieht
einfach nichts wenn man in so ein
gebäude drin ist ist es der overkill
dass der absolut okay aber wir sind
tatsächlich gerade auf platz eins
wir sind auf platz eins und meist kommen
die kiste transfer ganze valuten können
ja wie haben die kiste schon mal safe
switches das ist alles wichtig fürs pvp
und hier alles gut wir sind soweit auch
klar oh gott wie komme ich jetzt da hoch
so komme ich hoch und hier komme ich
auch hoch ok und das solo das ist der
beste beweis dafür dass man entfernen
einfach gar nicht einschätzen kann
ich würde fast nochmal zurück gehen hier
das ding mit schwung zu nehmen und
einfach drückt uns die daumen leute
drücken sie die daumen
jawohl wir es geschafft leismann alters
läuft es läuft oh gott das kt modul ist
auch ziemlich schwierig da bin ich sogar
ohne f5 auch nicht so safe hier wird
jetzt im modul zu modul 9
er wolle dass mensdorff und hier um das
ist teilweise richtig buggy hier also
teilweise springt man ganz normal ab
mannschaftsteil ist ob man's nicht
geschaffen und wir haben eine weitere
kiste die wir mitnehmen können
sehr schön nichts spannendes rennen
nicht allzu gut ist aber wichtig
nichtsdestotrotz und jetzt muss jetzt
mal zurück glaube ich komme jetzt hier
wieder hoch
genau darauf und hier alles klar
meistens auf diese these
das ist ja wohl mal der absolute
overkill nein nein da darf man nicht so
weit springen das hätte ich jetzt echt
nicht gedacht dass man da nicht so weit
springen darf
nein man kann es ja doch nur einschätzen
also ihr seht ihr wie es ist der skin
selbst ist einfach genau davor wo man
endlich hinschauen will das ist verdammt
schwierig meistens geschafft und der
rechts beginnt der countdown irgendwas
reisen hier ja ja okay wir hatten
vielleicht immer geschafft aber jetzt
müssen es ganz schnell kippen leute für
steve nash denn es geht los
und wie wir es so kennen warten die
gegner in der pflicht das nämlich schon
der erste wechsel mit dem treffen nehmen
also wenn der zweite sind müssen auf
jeden fall raushalten lieber abstauben
ja sie gut aus die gut aussieht gut aus
wir holen die wir holen ihn sehr schön
als erster mann muss ein taktisch
kämpfen wenn man hier mit der 5 fuß
unterwegs ist und wir können natürlich
auch super um die ecke schauen dass ich
ihnen gerne sache wenn auf jeden fall
schon abstoppen sauber ja unser erstes
ich hätte gerne mein schwert eine hand
wäscht die andere hand hatte ich gerade
die angel in der hand ich sehe es halt
nicht leute ich sehe ist guckt wenn man
kalt er so dasteht dann sehe ich alles
klar aber man lernt neues team schreibt
er
dankeschön ich weiß ich kann sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr gut team beste team at
sixteen oder und das was jemand der ins
cockpit auch sehr schön kiste luton
nicht sparen ist drin aber wir haben auf
jeden fall noch mal ein tier gerettet
das freut uns doch jetzt gehen wir eben
nicht die angel aber unbeschwert und
hängt er hängt sehr schön
ja ja ja ja wohl jawohl jawohl wollen
hessen wolle zeige ich den roman die
andere hinterherwerfen hoffen dass er
verbuggt loya r bleibt hängen spam
einfach ich sehe nichts ich sehe nichts
ich sie gar nichts lol und haben geld
irgendwie hierbei von logistep robert ja
wir haben die lagerhalle forstet dann
hinter uns könnt ihr mit dem publikum
mit naef chemical mitgenommen chemical
mitgenommen und der division uta uns
noch los und jetzt ist nur ein was man
schnell mal alles sortieren cobra die
tsg hat die schlechtere rüstung kann er
das hier rausholen
oder wollen wir es verdammt ist es
verdammt trick niemand aber könig
stellen um die ecke gucken auf jeden
fall sehr schön um die ecke gucken und
da ist er nämlich jaja haben die förster
gelandet es sieht gut aus die glocke wie
ein irrer okay erst beim tor mit der
hacke ist auf jeden fall hinterher in
der gegner schüssel als immer gut da
wohl okay jetzt können wir gucken com
erfolgen könnte trotzdem auszuweichen
aber der krieg auf den vordermann hält
würde ich sagen jawohl das rheiner da
jetzt erst mal gerne hinterher wollen
wir stehen bei neuen herzen er mit
sicherheit nicht
mal schreiben so geht es nicht weiter
wir haben uns den gewissen alter schwede
ggf 5 modus jawoll leute nicht gerade
locker 23 minuten hinterher gerannt aber
am ende hat sich ausgezahlt aber als
gedacht hatte und wir haben ihnen dann
will ich sage nicht dass gefallen hat
gerne einen leiter lassen und in die
kommentare schreiben was sie sonst für
den abriss wäre es gemacht hat bleibt
nichts mehr übrig außer zusagen bis zum
neuesten video und macht's gut